[Music]
thank you
I like both of these people in this
video so let me start by saying that
Rose aging weird
micro is older than you think that's why
you say that
uh let's see how do you think micro is
61. 60 you nailed it wow now damn wow
around the nose almost
uh he knows his old men that's for sure
those old man um in in biblically the
way Bobby Lee does right biblically
that's great so a
um this is micro with theophon
I'm trying to find a better way to make
a better golf ball knowing full well
that some knucklehead who's been amusing
himself
it's going to take one put it in a vice
and cut it open and see what makes the
world
what uh what's keeping you busy these
days sitting here with Mike Rowe thanks
so much for coming in sure
um and congratulations for uh for being
in Nashville and for carving out a
carving out a piece of something real I
mean this is so you know I do a podcast
too it keeps me pretty busy everybody
does man it's okay I'm on the road all
the time so I'm doing it on like
Riverside or Zoom or you know and it's
not the same as you know sitting in an
upholstered chair with the guy in his
house with the you know it's it's like
cable access way to docs him meets okay
yeah real I mean honestly like we're
this far from Wayne's World
and people are watching like lots of
people are watching so congrats on that
oh thank you man yeah I think we've been
looking for different Studios recently
but there's a level why full of
not I don't want to there's a level of
rogueness that has to accompany a
podcast Joe roganis s space yeah it's
like in L.A because we have a studio in
L.A
[Music]
there's a Chase Bank in the lobby that's
not it we need like a missing person
poster within 60 feet it doesn't need to
be on the building but you know what I'm
saying there needs to because there's a
level still of grunge to it you know
right right um that I think always needs
to be there if I walk into a corporate
place I am there's no grunge in
podcasting anymore man I hate to break
it to you yeah I know everyone's doing
it there's no barrier of Entry anymore
it's not punk rock anymore
and my head feel more corporate it's
just free therapy for some people right
and so it puts me in a different
headspace
um so I'd imagine it does that for other
folds although Marty McFly drip I gotta
like that Marty McFly drip yeah but you
can't man you looking like looking like
you're about time traveling some kind of
DeLorean or something man what's up you
about to blow up your sneakers man a lot
of hoverboard or something man what's up
with you what's up with that hat bro
that's his whole that's his whole bit
yeah right I mean if you're gonna be in
a corporate space there's a way to
behave that's consistent with your
surroundings and when people look at
that they might not like it but they're
not okay that's a good question the
microbottom I'm gonna ask you
if we the way we do this show right if
we had to go into a building where other
people are doing let's see let's use a
blaze just as an example well there's a
whole bunch of people doing shows at the
same time do you think our show would be
the same I kind of I don't know if it
would would it I mean maybe I'm just
wondering like
do you think it would be I don't know
there's someone at first there's
something no go ahead yeah eventually
you would just like just [ __ ] keep
going back and forth with people and
then [ __ ] get dirty looks and [ __ ]
you could eventually just modify your
behavior
I just worry about that I want to get
along with people I mean outside of the
show maybe but as far as the show itself
I don't think we've changed like yeah
I'd probably be respectful I'd try to
not be you know groping [ __ ] you know
female co-workers in a movie and stuff
like that but I I'm just making up a
hypothetical right like let's say you
drunkenly started grabbing people's
breasts yeah everyone had to take a
settlement like that's just to prove
that you're not gay like Ralph said it's
I'll show this [ __ ] you just started
spiraling I'll show him it's [ __ ]
knock me off look would like the guy or
not it's a real curse but no I think it
would help a show I think going into a
building and doing it I I think that's
like look it's like elon's making that
[ __ ] case right now for Twitter
employees like get your ass into work
[ __ ] the collaborative collaborative
effort works better when everybody's at
work we get there like you know half
hour hour before the show everyone sits
down we talk about some [ __ ] before we
you know because otherwise you end up
with that [ __ ] golden shower where
everyone shows up and [ __ ] one guy
just throws his sunglasses down on the
table and the other one's eating a
meatball sub and everybody's like what's
up what are you doing for Christmas what
are you doing what are you doing for
March Madness like what this is a
[ __ ] show this is a pre-show
conversation hey what are you doing
around Christmas time were you gonna go
see the family gonna come here that's
something you do while you're all right
guys we're alive the back there's like a
meatball sub it's just so this is such a
disrespectful food I don't know why it
is it it's breakfast food right to do it
yeah it's the old already Lang right
yeah yeah I'm not gonna judge you for
being a sellout or a fake or a poser
like you don't think so huh well not I
mean I'm not I'm not saying that came
off a little uh but they might yeah oh
you don't think so uh came off a little
bit Outsiders well I mean it's like if
when I see somebody uh working hard to
be grungy
I don't see it as much different than
somebody who's working hard to be
corporate if you're working hard
to create an appearance then you become
part of the production
it is true and you kind of Wonder I what
I'm and there's a little bit more we're
gonna play here but here's what I'm
reading because you specifically talk
about the LA Studio the one that used to
film all the stuff and he left her he
moved back to Nashville that's where
he's doing his show now so the thing
with that was I guess you're tired of
flying back and forth to show I I get
that but like
I'm wondering if the reason that that he
that Theo left was because it was
getting to
like oh this is a job now I have to go
into this [ __ ] business where like
you we talked about it like the king and
the sting and the sorry the golden
shower and and like three other shows
are there like you know like like
something to talk about so I'm talking
about something that should be the name
of the show by the way so I'm talking
about and and all these and all these
shows are like and there's this
Warehouse like this podcast thing where
I was like you brought up yesterday like
a cam girl site like it's a cam girl
thing right
it kind of does
for some people make it feel like oh
this kind of sucks right like what set
am I on you know
and if you're part of the production
then you're part of the enemy to
authenticity can I do in my show my
underwear that's another reason that's
kind of [ __ ] so comfortable city um
and I and
what I take from what you're saying is
that the thing that's for sale in the
podcast space that is also for sale you
know in any good I think you mean pod
space I was listening to this big gay
lion who called it that yeah hey Mike
why don't you come on the Pod bro
act uh in any TV show that feels real
and any song let me get my grow on and
have them have all these really like
humble and based takes and have like a
good conversation just wait for him get
like really in a good train of thought
and go
shut the [ __ ] off
just to see him go wait what he's such a
nice guy too
honest [ __ ] smug [ __ ] oh he's like
wait a minute I haven't been being so
long at all I think we could probably
get micro on I have I think we could
probably do that start using like start
using incorrect words to insult him you
know you're being really smarmy right
now and it's like I I haven't been smart
you know what I'm going to call him Mike
sanctimonious
Mike this sanctimonious like the
sanctimonious
I would actually like to have him on I
think it'd be a [ __ ] great interview
is authenticity yeah all right and so
there's this weird trap if you if you
work really hold up we can't say her
name on the show it starts with a K okay
you can call her that okay you can call
it a weird trap
hard to create it well then you're
manufacturing it and that makes you fake
but if somehow or another oh that's
going through your side is like every
show in LA because when micro did
inadvertently I don't think he was doing
this to to to uh specifically go after
anybody but he just described the exact
essence of what we talk about with the
LA podcasting game it doesn't seem
sincere it seems manufactured that's
exactly right it's an assembly line yeah
we've been saying that for [ __ ] years
now about these [ __ ] and I think
he's right I think that's a really good
point it is just it's a manufactured
thing and then the set just all comes in
on wire like the [ __ ] Eric Andre show
exactly all the things just drop behind
you on a [ __ ] thing and then your
desk slides up it's a [ __ ] Lupe
Fiasco video you can function in your
space ask the questions you want to ask
give the answers you want to give in a
time frame that you want to create you
know you then then I think people will
at least give you a listen right that's
a good point so maybe I'm over maybe I'm
giving that too much credit maybe you
know
maybe like I know on dirty jobs that
I mean great show by the way Dirty Jobs
was one of those get high [ __ ] watch
I used to love it yeah I think the
reason the show lasted as long as it
lasted was because we never did a second
take
it was I just said look if I'm going to
do a reality show you mean like [ __ ]
five take bro five take live read
Brandon chop he knew he pre-records his
[ __ ] live reads that's why sometimes
wearing different shirts and stuff this
is back that's right I'm Mike bro and
join me on Dirty Jobs next week turn
page over for details hear me out
Dirty Jobs we'll host the show but we do
other people's podcasts to see what it's
like I like it you know we go to Ethan
Klein's podcast hang out over there for
a little bit or how about this hear me
out on this we do the inverse we do
clean jobs oh we go and just go take
like executive banking jobs for a week
no that's [ __ ] because you're gonna
get executive banker they're gonna make
me a janitor
well no all clean jobs we all get good
they're going to give me the cleaning
job oh that's good yeah clean jobs
[ __ ] no